while tens of thousands of migrants are
fleeing bangladesh's capital daca
amid a surge in coronavirus infections
the spike has prompted the government to
tighten restrictions beginning monday
the lockdown will curtail most economic
activity and confined people to their
homes
now those who move to dhaka for work are
rushing to return to their home villages
before the lockdown takes effect
[Music]
thousands cram onto this ferry
hoping for a spot to get home
[Music]
being this close to others in a pandemic
isn't ideal
but they face a tough choice stay in
locked down dakar
with no work or support or go back to
their home villages
to be with family we have to accept
reality
there is nothing else we can do we are
simply victims of the situation
i am heading home what would we do
during this lockdown
it's better even to starve with my
family in the village
these ferries have been operating 24
hours a day
trying to clear the backlog and get
people home
authorities say they try to stop
overcrowding
but people's desperation means they
don't listen
[Music]
the exodus from dhaka was sparked by a
surge in coronavirus infections
case numbers have reached six thousand a
day
in response bangladesh's government is
issuing a stay-at-home order
with shops transportation and offices to
close
meaning many will lose their jobs with
no way to pay for food
or rent leaving these people with
few options other than to cram onto
these ferries
in an effort to find support in their
home towns